how much power do you have you have the
power to shape Europe how with the
European citizens initiative this is a
unique tool that enables you to shape
key you policies on issues that matter
to you do you have an idea about how to
tackle a challenge facing Europe do you
feel that your voice alone is not loud
enough to be heard with the European
citizens initiative you can join other
Europeans to make and support concrete
proposals in areas of the European
Commission's competences such as
environment consumer protection food
safety agriculture energy transport
culture non-discrimination humanitarian
aid launching an initiative requires the
involvement of at least 7 citizens
living in seven different GU countries
once your project is registered you have
one year to collect 1 million signatures
once these are collected your initiative
is presented to the European Commission
and debated in the European Parliament
you will get a response from the
European Commission with its decision on
what follow-up action will be taken
whether it results in legislation or not
the European citizens initiative gives
you the power to initiate change and
foster debate
you